um that's that's what happens when
you're reading the secret ation and
you're going to the series right but you
can just as easily go in the opposite
direction
can't you okay if I handed you this and
I said here is a partial sum of a
sequence right you can see that um is
this in this in a PGP now remember I
told you right for all the sequences
that we're learning there were two
important families that were you are
focusing on right we're gonna keep doing
that but just because there are two
families that doesn't mean that's every
day right yeah there's all kinds of
things out there right so this is
neither an AP nor a GP because if you
have a little bit the difference is
there's no comma difference all right
and if you have a look at the core ratio
there is it a common ratio okay so this
is not an apt theory but the
denominators are an AP and that's where
the pattern is forming right so if I
wanted to rewrite this as Sigma notation
okay how could I do this right well
first time okay now remember I need a
starting point then a missus starting
point I can start anywhere I like
so what would you like to just as a nice
commonplace place to start that's fairly
fairly standard to stuff oh I can start
from another value in fact in a second I
will start from another value and I'll
show you what happens now but for now
let's just go with this now the reason
what one of the reasons why and equal
fine is a great value start with is that
if there are one two three four terms I
automatically knew what the last term
will be it's gonna be term Dunbar four
right so first term second term third
term four terms where I'm going to end
okay now that's the tricky part what's
going to be over here what's what's it
going to look like right let's do the
easy part first what stays the same
every single of the terms
yeah good it's gonna be one over
something that's the easy part
okay so now I need to determine my
denominator now remembering that each of
these terms here forms an AP
just turn back if you still got it there
- Andrew our table
and we said what's the formula for every
turn in an AP generally speaking right
you started with your first turn and
then you added it ad minus one lots of
whatever that come a different one the
common difference was okay now I could
use this here pretty easily
goodnight so what's the first term of my
denominators that's one thing is you are
five five plus and minus one and what's
the common difference is 2 okay times 2
okay and this is really easy to simplify
now 5 plus 2 and minus 2 yeah
- and plus 3 are you happy with that
does it work N equals 1 2 + 3 5 and
equals to 4 plus 3 7 it works
ok now I could have done that
intuitively without appealing to a
formula I could have said there's a
common difference of 2 so whatever the
color difference is is going to be my
coefficient of my double you've done you
variable just like this is 7 right so I
could have said all right I'm clearly
going to get a 2n something and then I
think well what constant which made me
start at 5 rather than at - the answers
I've got to go up 3 right so I could
have intuited it if I wanted to but I
might as we use the formula could I have
it right ok so that's that now how would
this son she's really cooking how did
this change if I wanted to be awkward
and didn't want to start at 1 suppose if
you're like yeah you know it'll be a bit
of a hip stuff let's just start it
started three why not okay now let me go
through this process again if I started
three and I have counted one two three
four terms what would be my last six
right look when I need five take away
one that's four but there are five terms
we're gonna do four take away two
- but there are three terms just what's
these off-by-one errors they creep up
bust on us a lot especially when you're
working out a partial sum they'll say I
want this number of terms if you get a
plus one or minus one changes the Sun
doesn't I'm going to end up N equals 6
so 3 or 6 ok now again I'm going to have
1 over something right come on
what will be different this time now
this this one is to the same let me
suggest I'm starting in a different spot
right at N equals 1 3 rather than it
equals 1 but this is still an AP and the
color difference is still 2
do you agree with that still NEP yeah
still common difference - right
so I'm still going to have a to end here
good morning Hey ah but here comes the
difference right if I now think about
what my first term be my first time when
I put in N equals 3 which is my first
term of this partial sum right it'll be
6 but I don't what 6 on the denominator
on what 5 don't I write so how will I
just seeks to determine - 5 take away 1
right now just pause for a minute does
it what is the pattern going to make
sense well when I put in N equals 4
which is the next term I've got 2 times
4 which is a takeaway 1 which is 7
thumbs up okay now what have I just done
these two things they have the same
value I've no idea what that fractions
equal to but whichever way we take it
they can be equal to the same thing but
this is two different partial sum
expressions right because this is say
alright I have a sequence and it looks
like it looks like this 105 107
nine whatever 11 clearly keeps going
what with the next time be one of the 13
and 1 of 15 and run okay
now when you have a look at this guy
right this is still the same numbers
that I want except I'm starting at the
third term right so this is the first
term but over here that one fit is the
third term so there were two terms
preceding this sequence right there's a
term one term two that I become this
missing what with the young or the first
attempt if I just go backwards my back
crack will be a third and and what 1
over 1 right so do you see what this guy
is doing is saying okay my sequence
starts here give me the first four terms
there it is
right whereas this guy say ok my
sequence starts over here but I want you
to give me the third fourth fifth and
sixth terms right so here T 3 T 4 do you
get what I'm doing here
ok so it's just whichever serious you
want to start